hey everyone I'm Patrick Jenelle it's
Valentine's Day which means it's time to
do a little shopping if you're looking
for the perfect valentine's day gift for
a guy GQ and I have teamed up to find a
few gifts that might just hit the spot
this vintage schwinn bike is the perfect
gift for a guy who's trying to keep his
healthy new year's resolution it's a
great way to get around the city like I
do and my vintage schwinn bike maybe can
you twerk or even just take long
romantic rides on the weekend for the
stylish gentleman who needs to be kept
on time this movado watch is the perfect
v-day gift maybe it says I'm a spy in
between secret missions or maybe it just
says I'm late for a very important
meeting either way cool very cool if the
guy you're shopping for is all about
content then you need to get from an
ipad air this is the ultimate gift for
anyone who wants to play games post pics
update their status and stream movies
all at the same time it's light and
portable and ready to keep up with the
busiest guy like me those are my pics
from me and GQ happy Valentine's Day